17 that's how many senators are still
serving in the US senate since c-span
two began live coverage june nineteen
eighty six c-span covering Washington
like no other now a Senate hearing on
the troubled asset relief program known
as tarp over the weekend Treasury
secretary Geithner's said there's about
a hundred thirty five billion dollars
left in that program for stabilizing
financial markets the witnesses at this
hearing are in charge of providing
oversight of the fund and talk about
what's being done to prevent fraud and
abuse in the program this hearing is
about an hour 40 minutes Pure's
Committee Chairman Max Baucus
Congressman Jim leach said the banks is
rather surreal accounting practices
since then the world of banking and
financial oversight has become if
anything yet more surreal whatever one
of our witnesses today the special
inspector general for the Troubled
Assets Relief Program as calculated that
in the tarp and associated programs
taxpayers are potentially at risk for as
much as 2.9 million dollars two point
nine trillion dollars is just short of
what the entire federal government spent
in fiscal year 2008 it's like having a
second United States government budget
dedicated solely to saving the financial
system and that is truly surreal the
chart behind me outlines what makes out
that 2.9 trillion dollars that 2.9
trillion dollar is does not include the
400 billion dollars that the Treasury
Department has pledged in support of
fannie mae and freddie mac that 2.9
million dollars does not include the
resources of the federal reserve is
dedicating to shore enough financial
system in addition to the programs with
the tarp those additional accounts we
come up to about three trillion dollars
and that 2.9 Troian does not include
this second tarp that requests for 750
billion in the President's budget
if all these additional amounts
materialized taxpayers could be on the
hook for a total of more than seven
trillion dollars this is a huge
unprecedented financial commitment it
strains the comprehension of taxpayers
and policymakers alike it has been
nearly six months since congress created
the tarp program almost all of at seven
hundred billion have been committed so
it's time for the finance committee to
survey the many oversight issues related
to this new Treasury Department program
I worked hard to create the office of a
special inspector general for the tarp
is something I wanted I pushed for it
strongly some resistance in the former
administration but we finally got the
provision in there and very proudly do
have the office a special inspector
general for the tarp I'm very pleased to
welcome mr. barofsky to the community
day so far as the special ID IG my
judgment has done a good job the latest
controversy involving the tarp program
centers on the AIG bonuses paid from
taxpayer money senator Grassley and I
introduced legislation to reclaim those
bonuses for the taxpayers and we are
looking forward to bringing that
legislation to the Senate floor and
pleased that the special IG is
conducting his own full investigation of
how those bonuses get out the door but
the AIG Fiasco is just the tip of the
iceberg there are many many tough
oversight issues connected with this new
program today we look at 12 major areas
of tarp involvement I hope to get an
update on each area from our oversight
teams the 12 areas are one capital
investment program for large banks to
the capital investment program for small
banks three Citigroup for bank of
america five aig six the term asset
backed securities loan facility
otherwise known as telf General Motors
gmac ninth Chrysler tenth the mortgage
relief program eleventh small business
program
12th the bad SS program announced just
last week I hope it at least one of our
witnesses can comment on each of these
12 program areas will also serve a some
other key issues on which our oversight
experts have been focusing during the
past six months for one I pleased that
improving transparency has been a
priority for the special IG it's very
important this browski recommended that
the tarp posts all tarp agreements
whether they're with recipients or with
its vendors on the Treasury website and
the Treasury Department has agreed the
special energy also successfully pushed
for oversight language in the Citigroup
the bank of america agreements requires
those banks to account for import on
their use of TARP funds in the late
january mr. Roth's keys sent each bank
participating in the capital investment
program a letter asking how they abused
tarp dollars this was a much needed
exercise had not been done before I'm so
glad that mr. barofsky sent that request
Americans want to know how their tax
dollars are being spent that's very much
the minds of American taxpayers I
understand that all of the 360 banks
involved have responded that's
commendable look forward to hearing the
special aiji's preliminary analysis of
the bank's reports what did they say in
their response I'm also pleased that the
special IG has made progress on civil
and criminal law enforcement I'm
heartened that he has reached out to the
FBI to US Attorney's around the country
to coordinate fraud investigations
related to tarp funds my concern here is
with such massive amount of dollars
dedicated so quickly that is bound to be
considerable fraud and misuse of funds
just so many dollars allocated in such a
short period of time as which roskov
says of the primary oversight by
reference to the tarp bill the special
IG stands as the sole oversight body
charged with criminal law enforcement
authority especially IG is literally the
cop on the beat finally the new program
announced last week by administration
and Fed Chairman Bernanke represents
another huge challenge to our oversight
teams
the plan to purchase so-called bad
assets will evolve up to 100 billion of
TARP funds they will involve backing
from the FDIC in the Federal Reserve the
total commitment for this new program
could reach 1 trillion dollars view
program presents another very tough task
for our three oversight teams they will
have to oversee pricing the assets what
entities are managing the assets and
taxpayers exposure for each group of bad
assets I want to thank our witnesses and
their teams for the hard work this is an
enormously complicated program the money
involved is mainline bungling totally
mind-boggling indeed the money involved
is surreal look forward to our witnesses
Everest to help explain their task in
ways will make it just a little more
real many questions asked Americans have
many question asked but not turn the
same Grassley Thank You mr. chairman for
calling this critically important
committee meeting and the hearing that's
involved on this very important subject
and first of all so I don't forget it to
each of the three of you I want to thank
you very much for bringing transparency
to this issue bringing out all the facts
that need to be brought out make sure
laws abided by laws are faithfully
executed money spent according to the
intent of Congress and I mean that for
all three of you but I want to
especially mention professor Warren
because so many times over the last
decade and a half you and I have been on
opposite sides of a very important issue
and we're probably still on the opposite
sides of that issue but you're really
boring in on this and I want you to know
that I really appreciate your work and
I'll probably appreciate your opposition
on that other issue more because of the
hard work you're doing on this it's been
a year since the collapse of bear
stearns and about six months since the
700 billion dollar troubled asset relief
program was created according to its
purpose Klaus the act was supposed to
help Treasury restore liquidity and
stability and financial system and to do
it in a manner that protects own values
college funds retirement accounts and
life savings preserve homeownership
promote jobs economic growth
maximize returns to the taxpayers
provide public accountability for the
exercise of this Authority and we're
concentrating on that public
accountability I had my doubts about the
creation of tarp and the way it was
right through Congress congressional
leaders paired the bill with hard-fought
tax legislation for Midwest flood relief
and equity for Midwest flood victims
compared to what Washington did for
Katrina victims I voted against the
second round even though I voted for
that first one because of interest in my
own state being connected with it but I
voted against the second round because
my initial concerns about the rest of
the bill were justified including my
concerns that limits on executive
compensation or too weak as soon as
Treasury received the funds that decided
to bail out big banks instead of buying
up toxic exits as they told us millions
continue to lose jobs and homes which
makes me wonder about the program's
effectiveness but you can't measure
effectiveness when you don't know what
the goals and objectives of the program
are or how the program is being run I'm
disappointed and frustrated that the
administration refused the committee's
request for mr. Kashkari to testify
today it would have been nice to hear
how he is gauging the success of the
program and so I asked that are
unanimous consent to enter my letter to
secretary Paulson a dated November the
12 2008 during his confirmation process
I asked secretary Geithner for his
commitment to respond to all my
inquiries including that letter there
are certain answers that only the
administration can provide and I'm going
to continue to push until we get those
answers objects to be entered well the
operation of tarp is troubling it is a
small relief to know that the program's
watchdogs you folks are doing your job
I'm proud to have worked with you mr.
chairman to create the Special Inspector
General who will be testifying today
along with the heads of these other
agencies and
a congressional oversight panel these
watchdog agencies are vital in helping
Congress and the American people keep
track of multiple tarp and tarp related
programs that crazier Department is
initiating Treasury has announced
several new programs just in the last
two weeks some of its own and some in
partnership with the reef edirol reserve
with so many so much happening so fast
and so much taxpayers money at stake the
need for quality oversight and
transparency has never been greater
unfortunately despite saying all the
right things about open government the
new administration has not made any
major changes aimed at making tarp more
transparent moreover I have heard about
potential problems with access to
information from all three of the
oversight bodies testifying the Treasury
Department told the inspector general
that it didn't want to ask big banks
what they did with the taxpayers money /
provided through the capital purchase
program so the Inspector General said
that he would ask the banks himself at
first he faced a few bureaucratic
hurdles but he has now received
responses as the President or as the
chairman has indicated contrary to the
claims by some that it was impossible to
know how the money was used I understand
that many of the responses provide a
very clear understanding of where the
money went I guess the money was not as
fun jable as we thought and in fact if
we want to know where the money went
with a little ingenuity you can get a
pretty good idea the Treasury's recently
announced initiatives demonstrate and
increasing reliance and partnership with
the federal reserve however these moves
threaten the ability of the general or
the Government Accountability Office to
monitor the program effectively that's
because the GAO is limited by statute
from examining Federal Reserve
activities that limitation is aimed at
ensuring the feds independence and
monetary policy however it's
unprecedented actions in the last year
have taken it far beyond traditional
monetary possible
policy from the standpoint of the
efforts to ease credit freeze the Fed is
no longer independent it is an inch of
the appendage I should say of the
Treasury Department and therefore more
political than the independence that
traditionally has chairman Baucus and I
have already introduced legislation to
expand Gio's ability to obtain records
from tarp recipients because the bill
that failed created the program failed
to grant Gao the authority that it needs
congressional oversight panel has also
had problems getting answers from
Treasury according to the panel's most
recent monthly report secretary Geithner
has failed to respond to key questions
that have been pending since even before
his time at Treasury and I've already
complimented professor Warren if these
oversight efforts are to be successful
Congress must be willing to provide the
necessary attention and support today's
hearing is an attempt to do just that we
want to know whether the Treasury is
taking these recommendations seriously
and making meaningful changes if not
then we need to help follow up and make
sure that the problems identified
through the process or fit are fixed
it's not about assigning blame it's
about making sure that government works
it's about making sure that the
government is accountable to the
taxpayers who are footing the bill with
everything that is a stake we can't
afford to have it any other way thank
you Miss chairman what times what a day
mr. chairman thank you very much senator
I'd now like to reduce the panel first
witness is Neil Barofsky a special
inspector general for the tarp second
witness is Elizabeth Warren chair of the
Congressional Oversight Panel welcome
it's warn their witnesses gene Dodaro
acting the controller general our
regular practice as you know is have all
your statements reduced the record which
will do and ask each views beef about
five minutes some
your opening statements and we get to
questions we have for you mr. [ __ ]
Thank You mr. chairman chairman Bachus
ranking member Grassley members of the
committee I'm honored appear before you
today and particularly honored to appear
on the celebration of the Chairman's
30th anniversary on the committee more
than 300 billion dollars has already
gone out the door and including the
recent recently announced programs as
you noted mr. chairman we will soon be
responsible for overseeing up to three
trillion dollars in 12 different art
programs today I'd like to talk a little
bit about two of the area's we've been
focused on the tarp recipients use of
funds and our proactive law enforcement
efforts back in December as part of our
drive to bring increased transparency to
the tarp we began asking Treasury to
require tarp recipients to report on how
they're using tarp funds other than for
Citigroup and bank of america Treasury
rebuffed our efforts in late January we
therefore decided to do it ourselves by
conducting a survey of each of the 360
for tarp recipients who'd received funds
by the end of January 2009 as you noted
we received responses from all of them
and although it will take us a couple of
months to conduct a thorough analysis of
that information one thing is clear
complaints that it was impractical
impossible or a waste of time to require
banks of detail how they use tarp funds
were unfounded well certainly not
uniform number of banks were able to
give us detailed at times even granular
descriptions of how they use taxpayer
money for example some banks describe
specific loans or lending programs that
they could not have done without heart
money a frequent response was that tarp
funds allowed the bank to become or
remain adequately capitalized so they
could maintain and not reduce the level
of lending in a down economy others
reported using tarp money to pay off
existing debt well one had to change its
original plans when another bank called
it alone requiring the first bank to
take substantially all of its tarp funds
to meet that obligation still others
detailed investments that they made with
tarp funds some talked about
acquisitions and others kept the money
as a cushion against future losses there
was also a diversity of how banks
monitor their use of tarp funds some
reported commingling the tarp funds with
other capital and making no efforts to
keep track others attempted to segregate
the funds and
steps is such as one bank reported that
it has signed a special tarp manager to
keep track of the money I believe
ultimately the survey strongly supports
my earlier recommendation to Treasury
banks can and should be required to
report on their use of taxpayer money to
provide maximum transparency and not
simply be asked report on the possible
impact of the funds such as giving only
lending activity the secondary I'd like
to cover this morning we've been our
most recent effort to fulfill our role
as was mentioned as one of the the only
of the four primary oversight bodies
with law enforcement authority as I've
recently been described as the tarp cop
to that end we recently announced our
task force the town has been described
as a trillion-dollar Federal Reserve
Program they'll be seated with about 80
billion dollars in tarp money it's
intended to lend government money on a
non-recourse basis meaning that the
borrower doesn't have to pay the money
back to investors to buy both newly
issued asset backed securities as well
as now toxic assets off of banks as
balance sheets we've been warning of the
vulnerability of this program to fraud
for several months and we converted
those warnings into action by putting
together a team of eight different
federal law enforcement and regulatory
investigative agencies including the FBI
the IRS the SEC vinson ice Postal
Service and the feds IG all to address
potential fraud our task force had its
first formal meeting last week and our
goal for it is not modest we intend for
to redefine the policing of federal
government programs by proactively
setting up a law enforcement response
before fraud occurs we recognize the
inevitability of fraud and Garth large
government programs especially those as
complex as the tough the task force will
give us an ability to capitalize in the
vast experience of its members to make
better recommendations to prevent fraud
before it occurs and to establish a
framework of trained experts they'll be
able to rapidly investigate fraud when
it does occur and we're currently
discussing expanding the task force to
the newly announced programs also
dealing with toxic assets finally I'd
like to note that there have been some
complaints the media recently that my
office is oversight efforts may dissuade
participation
our programs some might take this as a
criticism I do not the bank or financial
institution doesn't want to participate
in tarp program because it's unwilling
to disclose how its using taxpayer money
or because it's afraid of the vigorous
detection programs that we are
establishing for fraud it means we're
doing our job keeping such participants
out of the tarp only benefit the
American taxpayer chairman Bachus
ranking member Grassley members of the
committee that concludes my testimony
I'll be happy to answer any questions
you may have Thank You mr. Braus kia i
was born Thank you Thank You chairman
Bachus it's a delight to be here on this
celebratory day Thank You senator
Grassley particularly for the very
gracious remarks we have certainly
differed in our approach to some issues
but I assure you on the issues before us
now with the oversight of the seven
hundred billion dollars and what's
happening with the Fed and the FDIC
there are no differences between us and
I appreciate your support and I look
forward to working with you Thank You
committee for having us here today I
should start by saying I am not reading
from a tight script and therefore of my
views are my own and do not necessarily
reflect those of my panel members I just
want to remind you which one of the
three we are with congressional
oversight of our duty according to the
statute is to review the current state
of the financial markets and regulatory
system and to report to Congress every
30 days we are the policy and strategic
folks for you we are the smallest i like
to think though that that does not make
us the weakest we're a fairly tough
group we've done for hearings so far
we've done for monthly reports and we
have done a report on regulatory reform
our fifth report will be out next week
we work closely with the GAO and with
sigtarp we coordinate frequently we try
to be very careful to support each
other's work and advanced each other's
work not to overlap or to duplicate in
any way I want to start this by by
raising the central issue that we keep
raising and that's the one
what is the strategy that Treasury is
pursuing since our very first report
indeed the first sentences of our first
report we have asked this question over
and over what's the essential plan here
what's the idea that Treasury is trying
to pursue with the notion that if we
cannot have a clearly articulated plan
and some clearly articulated metrics to
see if we are accomplishing those goals
we can't really engage in serious
oversight so we start at the at the
front end of this process how its
conceived what it is that we're trying
to accomplish we have asked first
secretary Paulson and then secretary
Geithner for information particularly
including these strategic questions and
so far we have come up short in our
April report which will be released next
month we focus on the strategic question
we look particularly at what we can
learn from the financial crisis in Japan
in Sweden from the Great Depression and
from our own experiences with the RTC in
the late 1980s all of which we think can
help inform us as we face the crisis in
front of us now I just want to briefly
mention our earlier report so you have
some idea of the content that we've
covered we had a valuation report that
we issued in early februari this is a
report that started when we did the
capital infusion into the financial
institutions effectively the first 350
billion dollars of tarp assets at that
time at the very first report from
congressional oversight we asked the
Secretary of Treasury what were the
terms where the taxpayers being fully
protected in these investments into the
financial institutions I received a
letter from then secretary Paulson who
said these transactions occur at or near
par which means in effect for every
hundred dollars put in there's a hundred
dollars in stock and warrants that were
given back to the US Treasury we decided
to do our own
evaluation of that lots of
number-crunching brought in some
academic specialists on valuation and we
found in effect that for every hundred
dollars of taxpayer dollars put in we
got back about $66 on that day of stocks
and warrants this does not account for
the decline since that time overall you
do that enough times and in 350 billion
dollars we believe that we overpaid or
subsidized to the tune of an estimated
78 billion dollars in the first
go-around that was our februari report I
just mentioned a couple of our other
reports I'm glad to go through any of
these in detail we did a foreclosure
report last month our most recent report
our March report in which we developed a
series of ways to evaluate whether or
not any foreclosure mitigation efforts
are likely to be effective trying to
highlight what the elements are that
they need to cover up we discussed the
administration's plan which we believe
covers some of those metrics but not all
of those metrics and how this may be
deeply problematic we also point out the
need for better data that we cannot
evaluate these programs simply by making
big announcements we've really got to
have data to track to see if they're
effective in the ways we hope and if
they're not to make appropriate
mid-course adjustments we currently have
under way an inquiry about health we are
very concerned about the big downside
risks to the taxpayer and frankly the
substantial upside values to a small
group of financial insiders we are also
concerned that this continues to
subsidize the very kind of financial
instruments and arrangements that help
create this mess to begin with and we're
concerned about oversight of that
process we're concerned about
contradictory information on
implementation and we have requested
information from Treasury we are told we
will get more information tomorrow on
this we also have inquiries under way
about AIG we have a number of question
about the justification the cost the
terms the ultimate beneficiaries we are
particularly concerned about the opaque
nature of counterparties that has thus
far hampered oversight efforts we have
requested information on many points
including the decision-making process
and the risks involved here we are
awaiting a response our bottom line is
that in a crisis the country needs a
coherent plan with clearly delineated
goals necessary to maintain public
confidence and the confidence of capital
markets we believe it is critical to
have sophisticated metrics to measure
the success or failure of program
initiatives we also believe that
transparency and accountability which we
have called for repeatedly from our
first report and every subsequent report
are absolutely critical to having a
system that's going to work that's going
to help us pull this economy out of the
ditch we are doing our best depressed
Treasury to provide a clearer strategy
more transparency and more
accountability we are here as your
oversight committee to learn from you
more about what we should be doing and
to try to explain the work that we have
done thus far and the work in progress
I'm here to answer any questions thank
you very much that's very helpful mr.
dodaro good morning mr. chairman let me
add my congratulations to you on your 30
years of service his committee senator
grassley good morning members of the
committee good morning to you Jos role
under the troubled asset relief program
is really twofold we have
responsibilities under the law to review
Treasury's implementation of the program
report to the Congress every 60 days and
we also have the role of the financial
auditor of the tarp program in terms of
tracking the money make sure it's
properly accounted for we have thus
reported three times during the six
months once in December once in January
and our third report is being issued
today
now in those three reports we made a
series of recommendations that are
designed to improve the transparency and
accountability of the Troubled Asset
Relief Program among those series of
recommendations are three main themes
that I'd want to touch on this morning
first is the need for better monitoring
and reporting on the uses of the funds
under the capital purchase program now
we focused on the capital purchase
program because so far as a March 27th
199 billion dollars of the 303 billion
that's been distributed under the tarp
program has been through the capital
purchase program so it's been about two
thirds of the money distributed so far
our recommendation back in December was
a treasury needed a process to collect
information from the financial
institutions on how that funds were
being used and what their how it's
changed their total lending activities
after initially balking at implementing
the recommendation Treasury then began
collecting monthly lending activity
information from the 20 largest
organizations financial institutions
receiving the money we said that wasn't
enough in our January report we said
every institution receiving money should
be required to report back and recently
Treasury has agreed with that and now
every institution receiving the funds
will be required to provide monthly
reports on their lending activities we
also think that this recommendation had
an additional benefit in that the
announcement for the new capital
assistance program which will emanate
after the stress tests are done on the
banks going forward Treasury will
require more information upfront about
plan uses of the tarp funds and require
better reporting going forward so we are
pleased that our recommendations have
had good effect in this area and it's
very important to have this type of
information on a regular basis to
adequately assess whether the program is
achieving its objectives secondly our
theme of our recommendations has touched
on communications
strategy this program from the outset
has been plagued by poor communications
I'm pleased that it's getting better but
there's still a ways to go as you
pointed out mr. chairman there are 12
different components to this program
they've evolved they've changed the
initial intent the purchase toxic assets
was changed to the capital injections
the program has continued to involve I
think that the financial stability
planet was announced in February was a
good step forward to try to provide some
clarity more details coming forward on
the public-private partnership effort
have been encouraging as well and some
of the details of these programs still
need to be worked out but the mere fact
that there are 12 different programs
that they are leveraging our activities
with the Federal Reserve the FDIC and
other organizations really places a
premium on effective communications with
the Congress and with the public and
other stakeholders about the details of
these programs and so in our report
being released today we recommend a more
effective communication strategy on the
part of the Treasury Department is is
appropriate and needed in the coming
months a third main theme has to do with
the management structure of Treasury now
Treasury's office of financial stability
is responsible for managing all these
programs and from the beginning we've
been concerned that they needed to
higher up with appropriate numbers of
staff and people they've made some
progress in that area but they still
need to continue to bring on the proper
numbers of people with the right skills
we've made recommendations in the
contracting area to strengthen their
controls and contracting and internal
control mechanisms that are needed to
properly track an account for the money
manage conflicts of interest as well now
in closing I'd like to thank Senator
Grassley you senator Baucus center snow
for co-sponsoring the S 340 bill which
would give Gao additional authority to
examine the books and records and talk
to recipients of TARP funds
while we have not had a problem that
they given the evolutionary nature this
program we think this legislation is an
important safeguard and needed and we
would encourage the Congress to adopt it
there are also as Senator Grassley
mentioned some important limitations on
our ability at the GAO to look at
activities that are managed under the
Federal Reserve's monetary policy and
discount window operations that are very
important I'm very concerned that as the
tarp program has been leveraged to work
with the Federal Reserve in these
activities that this is going to limit
our ability to provide to Congress with
much-needed oversight that concludes my
opening statement I'd be happy to answer
questions thank you very much for sorrow
I guess the basic question that the
American taxpayers have and I think
everybody in this committee has is is
basically well what are the banks doing
with the money I want to make sure the
money's spent to wisely fairly
appropriately and efficiently and as I
understand it listening to you you have
some sense how the dollars are spent but
to you miss Warren basically felt that
the subsidy basically effective they
were 70 some billion dollars sixty-six
cents on the dollar basically it was
some paid back balanced against the
subsidy so I my basic question in his
own is also how are they spend the money
you've basically he said given us some
indication about that and listen to you
mr. Barofsky banks did respond your
inquiries but the responses are all over
the lot I mean they spent may lots of
different ways some were sponsors were
very generalized some were very detailed
and as I just I guess first we'll ask
you then if you're just a general sense
thus far as to how they spend the money
a sec question is going to be in of each
of you what additional powers do you
think you need we've talked about more
data chuckle more access you talk about
transparency all of you what additional
authority do you need
because because I believe American
public wants to know how these lawyers
are spent they want you to the three of
you to help answer that question at the
house until I'm very pleased frankly the
what you're doing thus far and I'm also
very pleased that that we did create
golf special inspector general I thought
of this office because we got it
especially ejido look at all the wasted
Iraq with this all the defense
contracting were tens of billions of
dollars or were discovered as wasteful
my thought was let's get this office set
up in the front end around the back end
you know beginning these programs we're
at the end of the programs and I think
it's having a bit of a salutary effect
in that regard but clearly there's a lot
of questions are answered my sense is a
lot of dollars are not being
appropriately spent but we could just
briefly mr. proske again say is get your
gentle pressure and how they're being
spent and they get it now let's ask each
the three of you what additional powers
do do you think are appropriate so you
can even more appropriately get the
answer those questions miss brosky Thank
You mr. chairman we're going to give you
a much better answer once we have had
the opportunity to stratify and analyze
all the data but anecdotally I have
reviewed a good chunk of the responses
and I think we are seeing is that it
really depends on the financial
institution how they use the money some
a good deal of the numbers that i
reviewed would not have been adequately
capitalized but for the avira seat of
TARP funds some of them weren't
necessarily where they needed to be at
the time they received the funds others
because of losses and downturn in the
economy wouldn't have maintained their
levels of capital and as a result what
they've told us is they're able to
maintain the same level of lending gets
a little bit the question no that was
Warren posed like what's the purpose of
all this and I think one has to know the
answer that question sundry before he
can answer the question it wasn't
properly spent what guidelines were the
banks given as to how to spend their
money what conditions thanks for giving
almost no guidelines there were some
restrictions on dividend payments there
were some restrictions
on stock repurchase and some
restrictions on executive compensation
but for the most part it was left up to
the banks what to do with the money and
i think the responses indicate that that
lack of freedom of what they had to do
with the money it really covers almost
anything that you would expect a
financial institution to do whether some
did use the did use the money to
increase lending according to the
responses some went to such details
actually listing the specific loans that
they wouldn't have been able to make but
for the tarp money others invested the
money and are keeping it in either in in
liquid assets like mortgage-backed
securities guaranteed assets from the
government waiting to see what happens
with the economy using it as a capital
buffer to be able to withstand any any
downturn in the economy will be able to
give you a good analysis but anecdotally
really does cover across the board as I
mentioned two banks had plans to
increase lending but then other banks
called in their debt so I had to take
the tarp money and use it to pay back
other top banks so this is where I sense
on this issue has been the press talathi
IG issue where a lot of the tarp money
the AG received went to a counter
parties and there's even though there's
no assessment whether this
counterparties really need to be paid
one mine Goldman Sachs they took a
hundred billion dollars now they say
they want to give going dollars back to
Uncle Sam and so are you yet in a
position to know who decided that those
payment should be made to those
counterparties and on what basis those
decisions were made mr. chairman we're
we're announcing an audit this week that
answers that directly that question we
received a letter from 27 members of
Congress last week asking us to to look
into that issue right now my audit team
is preparing the guidelines for that
audit and we're going to announce it
this week and you know we hope to
quickly bring an answer to that question
what the decision-making process a lot
of times it first expired i want to ask
other families person grass need an
excellent a Greek Wedding i start with
the premise that the public's business
ought to be public and the expenditure
this money I put in the category of Paul
maybe a few things like military secrets
and intelligence privacy and a very
narrow definition of executive privilege
outside of that everything we're talking
about and Congress ought to have access
to it under our constitutional
responsibilities of oversight that's
where I'm coming from so in order to get
this information I need to ask three of
you the same question but a little bit
different so I'll ask them one at a time
i'm going to start with mr. to darryl
you you know about the bill that Senator
Baucus and i introduced to have access
to books in the records of anybody that
receives tarp funds our bill has been
referred to the Banking Committee
unfortunately no hearing set on that you
said that in your testimony that you
supported that legislation can you that
would have been my first question the
second question and could you explain
why Jo needs this additional authority
how it and how limits your ability
report to us without it and let me ask a
second question right along with that in
your statement you mentioned a GL is
statutorily prohibited from auditing the
Federal Reserve's monetary policy
activities given the significant
emergency authority exercised by fed in
this crisis how does this limitation
affect your ability to oversee tarp
money first on s 340 I mean the reason
that we have limitation and that
legislation would help is under the
banking auditing act and associated
guidelines we have access to Gao to all
the information that the financial
regulatory agencies have but we do not
have the ability to go directly to
financial institutions to get the
information from them this your
legislation that you and Senator Baucus
and sort of snow have sponsored would
enable us to do that for all tarp
recipients we think that's an important
safeguard particularly given how the
program has evolved you know initially
if it was just purchasing the toxic
assets you know we would have had all
the authorities that we needed not it
shifted and it may shift again as things
go for it
this is an important safeguard we're
getting cooperation when we do ask but
as an auditor I'd rather have the
authority to go behind and be able to
get the information now with regard to
the Federal Reserve that's a very
important issue I am very very concerned
that the limitation that we have it's
one of the very few areas in government
that we're statutorily prohibited from
addressing now I understand why it's in
the legislation to protect the
independence of the Federal Reserve but
that's in normal circumstances and we
are not in normal circumstances right
now and as more and more tarp money is
partnered with funding and activities of
the Federal Reserve we have no ability
to be able to get any information from
the Federal Reserve other than publicly
available information that is not
satisfactory if the Congress wants us to
basically have this additional oversight
role we need a legislative remedy we
understand it needs to be carefully
crafted and we're willing to work with
the Congress in doing that mr. barofsky
I'm not going to go through a paragraph
or two we're explaining the problems
that you had getting around the
paperwork reduction act and but i do
want to point out that a spokesman for
inspectors general generally have
supported your efforts and that you
shouldn't have to go through that red
tape if you had been required to go
through the normal paperwork reduction
act procedures how much longer would it
have taken you to gather the information
from the bank's on how they use the
taxpayers money could the Treasury have
required to has could the treasure have
required that banks provide the same
sort of information that you gathered on
how they would use the taxpayers money
as a condition of receiving it in the
first place and why didn't they require
banks to provide the information those
three questions senator Grassley on it
thank you personally for helping us cut
through that red tape but the answer is
it would have taken us at least three to
four months to get through the paperwork
reduction act by a normal procedure had
we not gotten the emergency exception
the answer your second question yes a
Treasury could can and should require
the banks to report on their use of
funds and then can you tell me why the
Treasury didn't do that I think that
that question we best posed to to to
Treasury itself I think mr. Kashkari is
said in testimony that due to the
fungibility of money that they may have
questioned the usefulness of that
exercise I don't want to speak for him
but I think our response to our survey
indicates that not only is it is it
useful I think it's important miss
Warren has a congressional oversight
panel had sufficient access to all the
information it needs in order to be do
its part of overseeing tarp and what do
you need that you haven't been provided
senator we are your congressional
oversight panel our concern right now is
that we do not seem to be a priority for
the Treasury Department we have sent
letters we have requested that there be
someone named so that we can get
technical information and so far we have
not been a first priority we use what
you give us and we will exercise the
leverage given to us by Congress in part
that's why I'm here today I'm here to
talk to you about what's happened so far
what we have discovered so far the
inquiries that we have in midstream and
for which we continue to await responses
that's where we are senator thank you
says no thank you mr. Chairman I want to
thank all of you as well for your very
substantive and crucial testimony when I
find absurd frankly is the fact that you
all really seemingly have to struggle to
get an answer tain information in order
to fulfill your responsibilities in
oversight of this critical program that
ultimately would yield confidence for
the American people if they had
transparency and could definitively
point2 results that have been
accomplished as a result of the three
trillion dollars that have already been
issued and my concern
as I look from you know my perspective
the people I represent in the state of
Maine they don't see the program working
as is you know what they've heard about
the bonuses not only IGS and wide and I
attempted to address that early on
through the stimulus package to address
all bonuses committed and issued in 2008
through January 2009 of eighteen point
four billion including Merrill Lynch
that issued about 2.5 billion in
december three days before they required
by Bank of America well the list goes on
but the fact is are not seeing in the
definitive evidence to suggest that it's
working the credit markets are very very
tight and based on the Federal Reserve
survey recently indicates that the
markets have tightened considerably and
most especially for small business that
a job generators and what i hear is a
common theme among all three of you is
that there are no consistent standards
for oversight that you really have to
struggle to get information from the
Treasury Department and that there's no
clearly articulated goal as you said
miss Warren what do we need to do
besides on the in the powers issue what
standard should we set in place for top
recipients for example to have to
disclose and to document how they're
using their funds and also whether or
not they're lending because that is the
other crucial concern the money is not
being used to lend appropriately even
those healthy banks are not lending
which is also freezing you know the
ability on Main Street to open the doors
or their closures that has led to as we
know historic unemployment rates so mr.
Baran scheme is war mr. dodaro can you
answer that question we need to do
something quickly I believe because in
every testimony that you have given all
three of you in your perspectives it is
abundantly clear that we have to do
something to not only give the
enforcement powers but the standards
that essentially have to be agreed to
and adhere to abide the Treasury
Department implementing this three
trillion dollar
I mean I would say to begin with to
support us and to continue to press for
greater greater transparency it's it's
it's very difficult to to make a you
know the policy determination without
having all the information that's one of
the things that we've we fought to do is
to bring that level of transparency so
we can see where the money is going and
I think indeed senator pressing on what
is success what is the measure of
success is an important question that
has to be clarified well I would hope
that we could get a list from you of
exactly what should be required to
treasure in each of you because i really
think that we should you know
incorporate that into law so that there
are consistent standards ms born yep
senator I I think you put your finger on
on the central problem here I want to
say this problem starts with Treasury in
the following sense there's not a bank
in this country that would lend money
under the terms of take the money and do
what you want with it if they're lending
to businesses they ask businesses what
you plan to do and most importantly not
just what you plan to do not saying
afterwards although I'm very glad that
mr. Barofsky has asked but in advance
what will be the metrics how will we
know that's what you did accountability
doesn't just don't I used it for all the
good things that I used my money for all
the bad things it's it's that you make
it clear up front this is what my books
look like now and this is what they look
like after I get the money and this will
be the difference between the two and
this is how you can see how American
taxpayer dollars were used so I'm
talking about accountability in a very
real sense of this word as I see it you
really have two options here either you
get Treasury to get some religion on
this point and and and put their own
standards in place or Congress is forced
to step in we will do everything we can
on your behalf as your congressional
oversight panel but what we can best do
for you now is to identify and pinpoint
that this is precisely where the problem
starts and then the problem has rolled
down affects all the way through the
system of lack of accountability
complexity that no one can figure out
what's going on
that we never identify the place where
we need to start the solution mr. dodaro
and I couldn't agree with you more in
the metrics issue absolutely to measure
in advance instead of reacting but being
proactive and having out fronts and
everybody is on the same page about it
mr. dodaro our philosophy on this has
been threefold number one it's
Treasury's responsibility as the
disperser of the money as the manager of
the program to collect this data and to
report it publicly and to the Congress
and to do that that we recommend that
they build upon an already existing
mechanism that the regulator's use with
quarterly call report data from the
financial institutions they get
information every quarter its audited
regulators review it we suggested though
that it needed to be collected more
frequently and that's why we suggested
monthly information now they've moved to
do that for the 20 largest institutions
for the last couple months that's good
they've reported that that's good
they've now extended it to all
institutions right now there are over
500 and I think 32 institutions have
received money there's another eleven
hundred and ninety that are with
Treasury for decisions and another 750
that are still with the regulators to
recommend the Treasury so you're going
to have hundreds of institutions if they
use the or implement our recommendation
successfully this should greatly
increase the transparency over this
program and then the call report data
that's audited could be used to verify
the reporting of the monthly survey
information with thirdly we've also
collected and started the develop a set
of indicators about specific interest
rates and also the spread between
interest rates and Treasuries which are
used to measure credit risk and these
market basket of indicators can measure
whether or not in totality the tarp
program and other activities are
improving the situation so far the
records been mixed just n case w thank
you very much mr. chairman and thank you
to each of you for the work that you're
doing we desperately need it there's no
question that the public has a right to
distrust
this government government recovery
process that's gone on here because of
as you've described lack of transparency
lack of accountability people who
institutions who have taken the funds
and hoarded them or use them for
excessive bonuses to reward failed
business models or and otherwise use
them for purposes outside the original
intent so that this administration has a
huge task in front of it and and we urge
them all to be moving with full speed
and I know they're focused on it but
there's so much needs to be done I want
to ask you specifically about one piece
of the program and how it compares to
others yesterday the president announced
further sacrifices that are going to be
made by people in my state as well as
across the country in order to create a
revitalized auto industry that the
president has talked about these were
part of conditions that were placed on
GM and Chrysler in order for them to
receive the tarp funds GM has been given
60 days to present a new viability plan
and this will bring it to five months
since GM became eligible for the tarp
funds so here we are today six months
after funds have begun to be given to do
oversight and yet we've not asked the
same requirements of the financial
institutions that have been asked of the
auto industry not only have these
institutions not come under the same
scrutiny but they've not provided the
information to prove that when the
crisis is over these companies will be
viable will be able to survive future
downturns and so my question is what
should be done to ensure that at the end
of the program we will have revitalized
financial institutions that will be able
to make it on their own and what lessons
can we learn from the rigorous oversight
of the of the auto industry to
learn from that and place it on the
financial institutions that have been
receiving power funds senator gasps oh
thank you I I think that this starts at
the beginning with a question of policy
and approach with the financial
institutions we could take effectively
one of two approaches we could say we're
going to subsidize them and subsidize
them for however long we decide to
subsidize them that gives us no
guarantees other than however we may
decide as we go along to put some new
strings in place the alternative is to
say we're going to reorganize them we
are actually going to and reorganization
typically means that the senior
management may be taken away it may mean
that a lot of stakeholders have to share
in the pain that bondholders are written
down and have to bear much of the loss
of of course at a financial institution
depositors we must protect we have our
insurance guarantees that we've made
with FDIC and other institutions but
this very real I'll talking about what
had happened during the RTC for example
the crisis in the late 1980s and in the
late 1980s the position with financial
institutions was very straightforward
the financial institutions that were in
trouble were liquidated the people in
charge lost their jobs of debt holders
took a substantial losses the equity was
wiped out and the depositors were fully
protected that is one approach it as an
approach that was also used in Sweden
there was real confidence in the system
about those that remained indeed those
that remained were able to pick up the
business of those who were failures and
were ultimately able to thrive taking
the different approach and that is
continuous subsidisation without
rigorous oversight is precisely what has
led to the difference now that we're
seeing between the approach with the
auto industry which is much more modeled
on a reorganization approach and the
approach that is being used throughout
the financial services industry and that
is a straightforward subsidisation
so I see this as an issue that starts
right back at the beginning which of the
two plans that Treasury is putting in
place which of the two strategies it is
following and this is the debate we need
to have quite frankly Congress with
treasury of we're part of this debate as
well just say this is the real question
do we think that subsidies lead us to
the right place or do we think
reorganization does that when if I might
just say that on the one hand I mean you
missed and just to add to the group of
people being hurt the main people being
hurt other people who are losing their
job of course and the communities where
the plants are being closed and
reorganization in my state means job
loss and means plant closings and so
there's very real efforts and very real
sacrifice going on what I see on the
other side our banks that have been
given money and aren't giving the loans
a senator Snowe was talking about we
small businesses are losing their lines
of credit in Michigan people who have
paid on time forever you know can't get
a loan suppliers can't get a loan to be
able to do business with the auto
companies as they normally would do and
so huge discrepancies and mr. Chairman I
look forward to working with you further
to look at the two models being used
here in terms of accountability on one
side and total lack of accountability on
the other side thank you I can make a
point senator I do think part of its a
cultural difference New York
establishment the financial
establishment is but thick generally
with the financial establishment in
Washington DC it's a totally different
culture from the manufacturing other
economy establishment and I do think
that's one reason why they're each is
being treated a bit differently i gets
an issue and if I might just one more
editorial comment if we don't make
things in this country we won't have an
economy so thank you Sarah lichen Thank
You mr. chairman and I certainly want to
align myself with comments from Senator
Stabenow and snow about the importance
in terms of where these resources are
going and
who's actually benefiting I know that
the multiple small businesses that call
me are saying the same thing we are a
longtime customers we have good accounts
we can't you know these these financial
institutions are not loaning the kind of
resources that we need for operating
budgets and other things like that and
it's just not reaching down and I agree
wholeheartedly with the chairman it is
cultural difference there's no doubt
about it if you look at how this this
country was established and business the
success of business 60 years ago was
determined by whether the business was
creating jobs and whether it was
reinvesting in its company and whether
it was reinvesting in its community
right now obviously the problems we see
from Wall Street are not the fact that I
mean nobody if there's reinvesting in
themselves they're just leveraging and
leveraging and that's become a real
issue so we appreciate the Chairman
bringing us together on this hearing and
certainly appreciate all of you all and
hope you won't go far because we'll need
you as we continue I think the other
thing is is that building confidence and
trust which is a huge part of this
equation among investors and among
working families across this country I
mean that's a task that humanity has
dealt with fur eons and it's going to be
something we're going to have to work
from the economic side but also in terms
of the humanity side of whether people
are willing and ready to be more
confident and Trust trusting of the
system that we put together and that's
going to be a critical part of it I just
one professor Warren I just wanted to
highlight a point that you made in your
testimony you said Congress has given
Treasury substantial discretion as
befits this fast-moving crisis and and
and that happened to a lot of us when
you know last fall we were approached by
the Secretary of Treasury and others
that said the sky was falling and this
crisis is going to happen tonight if you
all don't do something but you continue
in your in your testimony but that
discretion carries with it an equivalent
obligation to explain in real time why
the discretion is
exercise as it is I couldn't agree more
and one of the things we continued even
before we voted for the first tarp and
even after many of us have continued to
is to talk about how important it is to
have accountability and transparency and
to understand what the plan is if
there's not a plan and we can't describe
it to our constituencies we can't defend
the government playing a role in it but
you know the stakes are high and people
need a better understanding of how and
why their taxpayer dollars are being
used and we can't expect confidence to
return if people can't understand the
steps that are being taken to combat the
crisis and that's a real issue and I
hope secretary Geithner will take that
to heart and do more to explain on real
time basis what he is people are doing
and why I think they have a
responsibility to the American people I
know he's a technical person he's
extremely bright and smart and I think
ya can be very helpful but without a
doubt conversation and communication are
going to be critical in terms of
building that trust in that confidence
professor warn you you mentioned AIG and
from the sound of your testimony you
still have a lot of questions about that
assistance when do you anticipate that
you will receive the information that
you've sought from Treasury and that the
bed and the Fed regarding AIG and are
they being forthcoming and if not so
what do you need us to do to you know to
to compel that information to be
forthcoming well senator I I don't want
to over promised here we have been told
that we will receive this information
shortly but we are a panel that has
lived on you will receive this
information shortly and so I am I am NOT
without hope and I am hopeful that our
conversation may find its way to people
who are responsible for getting back to
us on this but we have substantial
questions about AIG we have substantial
questions I just want to be clear here
yeah
about the towel about the tarp to point
o the the cap how many acronyms can we
do here in the week which almost average
Americans don't understand well but
that's the point I mean I really want to
stop here for a second on exactly that
point when we have enough complex
programs that have you know lots of
wires and bells and whistles with no
articulation of what it's supposed to
accomplish and how we're measuring
whether or not it accomplishes that with
no underlying discussion about hey this
is a subsidy you know secretary Paulson
wrote me a letter that said as flatly as
you can this is not a subsidy when we
scratched the surface it was absolutely
clear that one out of three dollars was
a subsidy so when that's the case that
means there is no transparency indeed it
means Congress and the American people
have been cut out of the conversation so
transparency is partly about websites
and being able to track exactly who got
what dollars and that's an incredibly
important part of it but transparency is
about articulating upfront what you're
trying to accomplish why you chose one
half instead of another why one group of
people are asked to bear enormous pain
and why others are not that is the heart
that is the start of this entire process
and until we clearly have Treasury's
attention we have them focused on these
questions for purposes of a public
conversation I'm afraid we will not go
forward so Schumer Thank You mr.
chairman thank you thank you thank you
mr. chairman and just let me add my
congratulations to your 30 years as
chairman as quite not quite as chairman
that's coming but as member of this
committee when you became a member of
the Finance Committee I was probably in
within the month or two within the
speaker of the new york state assemblies
office asking him if he could please put
me on the this new york state assembly
Ways and Means Committee so I very much
appreciate what you've accomplished
and my question my first questions for
mr. Barofsky but I did want to welcome
miss Warren here because of the great
work she has done i have used your
studies on the fact that median income
in america has declined from 2001 to
2007 that's before the recession but the
average family was hurting even before
the recession i think if you had in
buying power you told me it would go
down to 43 thousand and we've never had
a period of prospects Oh called
prosperity we're median incomes declined
if you do average incomes of course it
raises it way up because if someone goes
from 30 million 250 million that raises
the average up but it doesn't raise the
median up a job and I think your study
is groundbreaking and I hope you'll
continue to work at that mr. barofsky
and welcome and thank you for the job
you're doing I'm concerned with the
estimate of the money that remains in
the tarp secretary Geithner has said
that's 135 billion dollars I noticed you
of a slightly lower figure of a hundred
nine billion there are outside experts
who believe it's considerably lower than
that some have said it's three times
lower you know in the 30 billion dollar
amount how do you account for the
differences which number should we
believe can you give us some feel for
this because obviously it's a very
important number sure the the primary
difference between our number and
Treasuries number is that they calculate
an anticipated return of 25 billion
dollars of money that's already been out
that's been invested that that banks
they expect banks to return because they
want to be out of the tarp because they
want to get out of the program and is
this a lot of banks returning a little a
few banks returning a lot do you know
Treasury hasn't given us the the back up
for this estimate this is something that
we just learned about over the weekend
certainly a number of banks have
publicly stated that they intend to give
the money back but when the rubber hits
the road they have to get regulatory
approval before doing so to make sure
that there's still be well capitalized
but large number of banks that have said
it ok I think that's difference between
us and and this as to the other number
that you mentioned the as little as a
third are number two before this weekend
was significantly lower than 100
9 Treasury has changed some of its
estimates they originally had 250
billion dollars for the capital purchase
program that's come down to 218 and
there's some other areas where the
original announced numbers have been
scaled back a bit which is why that
bottom number on the chart which is
what's left over 10 9.5 is where it is
mm-hmm and just explained that the
scaling back of the capital purchase
program sure I think they initially
estimated that that there would be 250
billion dollars that would go out the
door on that program they've now said
based on the number of applications
they've received and the timing there
now estimating it's only 218 just
professor Warren in your oversight
function do you agree that this is about
the right number we think it's about the
right number yes you agree with that mr.
Dodaro well I think at the at the
current moment it is but one of the
things that we want to look at or some
of these new programs that haven't
started as to the assumptions for
example in The Making Home Affordable
program there's a some some assumptions
underlying how many people will
participate at what levels and I think
you know we're going to take a closer
look at some of those assumptions so I I
would expect that the figures are going
to change a bit given the evolving
nature some of these programs and our
main point has been the Treasuries they
need good internal controls to track all
this there's also you know dividend
payments that are being made now those
don't go back into the program as if
principal does get repaid but all these
things need to be tracked and they need
to have good assumptions great finally
last question I don't have much time
conflicts of interest in the
public-private partnership have you been
focusing on that mr. Barofsky are their
guidelines are they adequate how do we
deal with that issue which is a very
significant issue there are no
guidelines yet I think it's going to be
an incredibly significant issue the the
way that there's three different public
private programs and it would take me a
while to go through all three of them
but I think one thing that they have is
in many of them you have those that are
setting the price who could benefit in
other areas of their business by that
price increasing
and that creates a very very significant
conflict of interest we've raised this
issue already with Treasury a meeting
tomorrow with the Federal Reserve to
discuss this issue and they're taking it
seriously so far they're taking it
seriously but it is a significant
content comment on that miss Warren the
one time's up we're also looking at the
structural conflict of interest that is
the way these are set up in order to
potentially reward people on both sides
it's the same person on both sides of
the transaction okay thank you mr. Jim
thanks that are sad ulations again thank
you sir Carper good next for the first a
question for our acting head of Gao I've
heard a lot of people testify over the
years and in fact we all have and it's
rare that anyone ever testifies without
notes I've seen you testify any number
of times you've never used notes how do
you do it I study or reports and I
listen to my staff no I I life is a
member of your staff sitting behind
whose lips move when you speak I know is
that what's going on I stay close to the
work and the that enables me to do it i
kidded him about this before it's pretty
amazing all right miss brosky yet I get
our thanks to each of you for being here
today inferred for your stewardship
larochka understand from your testimony
that sent out some 364 letters to each
talk recipient asking how they've
utilize the funds today and your
response rates but about a hundred
percent that's not bad I appreciate the
summer in your testimony as well as the
substance of the responses and that your
staff of analyzed to today there's some
concern we've heard it I don't know if
others on the committee heard it but
we've heard some concern from along the
banking folks the banking community that
those participants in the capital
purchase program not lumped together not
be lumped together with those who have
needed talk funny because they were too
big to fail and many of those in the
capital purchase program are just
satisfied by the way we in the
government they think been moving the
goalposts on them and changing the rules
of the
in some cases i'll give you an example
here's some of these folks didn't want
to take talk money they didn't want to
take the money the capital purchase
program money and we said we need for
you to and we need for you to take it
because not because we think you're
going down because we want to take the
stigma away from so the others who
really need the money will be inclined
to accept it but let me just ask if you
could give us some sense as to whether
you're hearing this concern similar
concern in responses you've received
from recipients of the tarp money and
the CPP money and our other responses
from the recipients of the CPP
overwhelmingly positive or they are
overwhelming negative rarely somewhere
in between we have heard those concerns
in our correspondents part of our
surveys not just for use of funds but
also how financial institutions are
dealing with and preparing to comply
with the executive compensation
restrictions and I have seen a number of
those letters frustration from these
banks from what they perceive to be a
changing of the rules and an indication
that they're looking to pay back the
money because executive compensation
rules have become more strict so I think
that it is something we have seen seen
in the correspondence and what if you
were sitting in our shoes and people
saying look you we took this money under
duress we really didn't want to and now
that we've done it at your encouragement
to take away the stigma now you're
changing the rules on it said that that
that troubles my sense of equity I don't
is it yours well i would say that but
when the the rules became more strict in
the Recovery Act Congress also put in
the the carve out that made it much
easier for banks to repay the money
before they would had to have matching
private equity equal to the amount of
the stake of this harp investment in
order to get out now if they if they
want to pay back the money they can pay
back the money as long as they maintain
their their kept their capital is
adequate as according to the regulator
so I think that concern has been
lessened by the Recovery Act one last
question it was report a couple of weeks
ago I think March twenty then at least
13 companies receiving billions of
dollars in bailout money Oh a total of
more than 220 million dollars in
unpaid federal taxes and as I understand
it banks and other companies receiving
federal monies were required to sign
contract stating that they had no unpaid
federal taxes but were not required to
produce their tax records you know if
this air has been corrected you know
where this investigation stands my
investigations division is coordinating
with Department of Justice and it's
under review alright thanks very much
and again we appreciate your being here
and your good work thank you sir
Menendez mr. chairman let me take a
moment of my time since I was both in a
banking and energy markup to
congratulate you on three decades of
service to not only your great state but
to the country and particularly in your
leadership of this committee you've
steered through some of the most
challenging and difficult issues that
the nation is face and you've done it
with extraordinary intellect and ability
and as we look at some of the major
challenges we're facing now I can't
think of a better person at the helm
particularly as we try to tackle health
care reform so I want to salute you as
well Thank You senator mr. Barofsky uh
you know when you came before the
Banking Committee for your nomination I
asked you a bunch of questions I want to
follow up on them now one of the things
is you have the power to pursue waste
fraud and abuse in the system as you
review this and I'm wondering whether
anything that you have done to date has
given you cause to pursue any of those
elements as you are reviewing the
documentation from the survey and other
information flows that you have I think
that in particular with respect to fraud
we are we're very concerned by the
design of some of these programs and in
particular the ones that have recently
been announced I think that there's any
time you push out trillions of dollars
even millions of dollars but certainly
trillions of dollars in a very short
period of time you run a risk and almost
a certainty of a large percentage of
fraud FBI estimates that I've seen is
that ten percent of any government
program is going to be vulnerable to
fraud that would be three hundred
billion dollars so that is that is
a keen issue for us and one that we're
trying to be proactive about we're we're
doing something that I think has not
been done before the government program
is that is setting up a task force of
different experts in law enforcement
community and training them now so that
they'll be ready if and when the fraud
hits and this does two things one
because of the the programs are so
complicated law enforcement isn't
necessarily comfortable with a lot of
the concepts with a lot of the the
mechanisms of the program so it gets its
sensitizes law enforcement be able to
react quickly and rapidly to any fraud
but second and I think even more
importantly we're going to have a form
of ideas to make recommendations as 383
which was supported by this committee in
which passed both houses unanimously you
know gives us strengthens our already
good strong power of making
recommendations if I may so you you have
the wherewithal you have some concerns
but at this point you haven't had any
reason to pursue any of the waste fraud
and Bruce because it hasn't come to your
to your attention oh no we actually have
your we actually have probably at more
than a dozen ongoing criminal
investigations based on fraud related to
the tarp program so that's what I wanted
to know unfortunately I don't expect you
to talk about those I just wanted to
know that you're pursuing oh no
absolutely senator that's one of our
primary mandates secondly and this may
be a hybrid question for both you and
professor Warren you know when we when
we also had your nomination we talked
about what the purposes of the Act was
and when I read specifically from the
Act which talked about restoring
liquidity and stability to ensure that
such authority is used in a manner that
a protects home values college funds
retirement accounts life savings
preserves home ownership and promotes
jobs and economic growth maximizes over
returns overall returns to the taxpayers
of the United States and provides public
accountability for the exercise of such
authority so the question in my mind is
have we met those goals as we can
envision as
what has happened today I'm concerned
professor Warren when I read from your
testimony both this time and then pass
I'm one of those whose was a big
believer in conditionality up front so
that we could have benchmarks and easier
acetate able ways in which we could
determine whether we're making success
and on page four of your testimony where
you say the most important lesson we
door from our analysis is that without a
clearer explanation from Treasury about
its overall plan for each capital
infusion and without more transparency
and accountability for how that plan was
carried out it is not possible to
exercise meaningful oversight over
treasuries actions could just talk about
that and mr. barosky could you respond
to that as well I thank you senator I
would make two points here the first one
is the good news point i want to say
there's a little bit of water in the
glass and a little bit of water in the
glass is we are not going to let these
goals be forgotten this is not going to
be a statute that you put a lot of good
language into it and then everyone went
off and just spent the money and forgot
what it was there for so I see our job
is to come back to you to go back to
Treasury to go to the public and keep
reminding them of these goals and
reminding Treasury why it is they need
to articulate what the plan is why they
have made the choices they have that
said it's only a small amount of water
in the glass because at this point we
clearly are not there and frankly I
think American people understand that
we're not there that we have not yet had
a statement of what we're trying to
accomplish why it is that some have to
take losses and others don't have to
take losses why there are no metrics put
in place in advance bus to condition how
the money spent and to test whether or
not it's achieving any goals on the
other end so we're not there we're just
simply not there it is not yet happening
with Treasury across gave it mr. Murphy
on family but would you care to comment
on yes I think senator you hit the nail
right on the head and that is putting
the right conditions on up
front the initial chart programs were
rolled out before we before we got there
since then one of the things that we've
been doing with every program in every
contract is making recommendations just
like the type that you mentioned
requiring internal controls on reporting
of conditions getting that up front so
we can keep close track of what's
happening i think that's that's vital to
what we do thank you Jim again how well
as Treasury complying with those up
front conditions for its anybody out
present that is setting them well for
this administration we're really going
to going to find out in the very near
future with the mortgage modification
program and the recent programs we have
and will continue to make
recommendations on a rolling basis and
now with s 383 having passed both houses
the Secretary will be required assuming
the president signs it into law the
secretary we require to their doctor
recommendations or explain to you to
Congress what why why he hasn't so I
think we'll have a very good mechanism
being able to keep track right I asked
earlier i said i was going to get you
what additional powers you think you
should appropriately have let's go down
the table that go down the list Darth
you mr. Barofsky what additional powers
do you think you should appropriately
have in order to protect taxpayers
interest i think i'm sorry but i think
to the extent there is any ambiguity in
our powers they were clarified by s 383
so for now i don't see any any issues we
will certainly as i promised during my
confirmation hearing before you we will
certainly let you know if we see any
other additional need but for now I
think I think we're good feel free to
come back is born a senator I would
describe it this way we need to find a
way to make these policy issues and the
articulation of these plans higher on
Treasury's priority list I'm not here to
ask for more power from Congress I'm
here to say that's ultimately what we
need we will use whatever you give us I
appreciate that but you're a knight
estate says Cindy are a red-blooded
American you know what what additional
power do you think someone in your
position should have to protect American
taxpayers well senator the
the question that would be appropriate
for Congress is whether or not Congress
wants to move to the next step which
would be having Treasury required to
consult with us on these issues and make
public statements i mean it's i'm just
trying to find ways to step in that you
can respond what we're asking for is not
rocket science here we're not asking for
something extraordinary unlike mr.
barofsky who actually you know really
has to get down at the papers he has a
badge for a reason we're asking for the
much broader articulation of what the
plan is transparency in the goals
transparency in the execution in the
strategy what we need is we need
Treasury's commitment and if that
commitment is better done by statute
then that would be that would be
Congress's decision you get the answer
that question mr. browski what questions
you ask your Treasury I'm talking about
conditions that's going to give you some
clue as to what the what the goals are
absolutely Sarah and part of our
reporting requirement is to set that
information out we asked Treasury with
our which each of our data calls on a
quarterly basis to give an explanation
for each of the programs on our last
report they just referred us to the
website but we're always hopeful that
they'll provide more detailed
information this time yeah I will go
there odaro but more powers yugioh will
have to get do the job I need the two
bits of help number one passage of s 340
would be an important safeguard for us
going forward I again appreciate your
and Senator Grassley's sponsorship of
that legislation that would be a big
help but even beyond that is the Federal
Reserve issue you know based on your
chart here most of the money in the two
point nine trillion dollars is being
spent under the tutelage of the Federal
Reserve activities and that's an area
where we're statutorily prohibited as
long as they're operating on a monetary
policy in a discount window
operations and open market committee you
know we just can't oh yeah you make a
good point the role the Fed has changed
dramatically so the visual defensible
shouldn't intrude the integrity and
independence the Fed I think the longer
applies we're talking about a role in
involvement which is beyond just
regulating the money supply there's no
it's a direct involvement trillions of
dollars which have very significant
effects inflation and potential
inflationary effects a real management
effects related to the Treasury does or
does not do imma clearly the Fed is
working in concert with the Treasury
their hand in hand them here and so I
think it's only appropriate that we find
some way to find out about other feds
operating word how it spent its money
and how recipients or using that money
to I don't know you also said we should
address this to constructive why did not
agree with you but clearly the role the
Fed has changed well I and therefore I
think we have to look more closely and
encourage the Fed to ask act much more
transparently than it has yeah and I
think in the short term mr. chairman
there could be some carefully crafted
legislation to give us authority either
piggybacking off and when they use their
emergency authority or not but I would
make this point also you know we've said
that there's a need to modernize the
financial regulatory system more broadly
speaking that the current systems
outdated fragment is and this whole
issue as that system has modernized the
question of proper oversight proper
accountability and proper transparency
will need be to be revisited in that
broader spot resources d other mr.
Barofsky the adequate resources to do
your job because you get a lot of
responsibility here we do senator part
of s 383 released the full 50 million
dollars that you had you had fought for
us to receive under the stabilization
act and and that will certainly take us
take care of us for the time being we
will be coming back more when the time
is the time is right to seek more
financial I thank you
from job you're doing clearly this
hearings indicates is it immense
uncertainty how the money's being spent
and Ike you all did a very good job and
trying to answer that question but I
also think that the you need a little
help from this claim from the Congress
mention legislation which is helpful but
we encourage you to keep up keep the job
up to achando and be very aggressive be
very aggressive and you run into any
problems at all you let us know because
we want to work with you help you do
your job so you're much much better
position to ask these questions that we
are but we want to give you a full
authority to go ahead and proceed so
this is this very very worse than the
potential exposure i benched my opening
statements close to six seven trillion
dollars you know we spent two point nine
trillion in the chart there as I said
misstatement units that's a size that
hold on States government last year so
we have two governments here one's a
chef one's a second government just
build enough national institutions
there's a lot of transparency and
accountability in the first government
you know it's next one is the issue here
and it's and we're trying to grapple
with and thanks for what you're doing
some Grassley and I've got to leave so
you can finish up okay thank you I only
have a couple questions so obviously I
won't keep you long so the Chairman can
hear this miss Warren maybe if you're
having trouble getting Treasury to give
you information if they'd like to sit
down have some senators sit down with
you when you're asking Treasury those
questions I'd like to hear them say why
we aren't entitled to this information
because the same people telling you know
come before this committee and tell us
they'll answer our questions and they
don't do it so you know I don't think
they're lying but there's a culture in
the end in not just in Treasury there's
a culture and too much of the
bureaucracy that you know we're going to
drag our feet as long as we can get away
with it let me senator Lincoln touched
on this a little bit but to miss Warren
about small business your panel has a
different job than I geez
or the GAO when it comes over so your
panels focused on policy I'd like to
know how you think that the tarp is
helping small business I consider them
the engines of growth job creation etc I
think seventy eighty percent of the new
jobs the overwhelming majority of tarp
money has however gone to large national
and even multinational institutions at
these institutions are ones that seemed
to be doing less lending after getting
the tarp money which means less money
for small businesses thank God our
community banks have stepped in and kept
up their responsibilities two questions
a one's a short one and ones long one I
want to ask them both at the same time
do you have any suggestions on how to
hold these large banks accountable and
number two also since the federal
government through SBA already
guarantees small business loans can you
tell me how Treasuries purchase of these
loans through term asset loan facility
telf I suppose this acronym will improve
small business owners access to credit
yes senator of I share your view that
small businesses are probably our best
engine for being able to get this
economy back on track in job creation
another every other kind of innovative
economic activity I want to coat back to
where I start this about laying out what
your plan is and what you're trying to
accomplish if the plan had been
announced from the beginning that what
we want to do is make sure that small
businesses have enough money to continue
to operate then I don't think we would
have designed the initial infusion of
capital into the financial institutions
in the same way it would have gone to
financial institutions who did small
business lending as a substantial part
of their operations and then it would
have gone on terms that said show us
what you have done in the past and show
us what you are doing after you receive
the money so this program was not
designed from the beginning in my view
to to focus
efforts on small business lending we
raised this question in our December
report we came back to it again in our
January report and now the place where
in is we're now rolling forward this
will be a significant focus not of the
report that will be out a few days our
April report but our may report we're
deep into investigations about small
business lending i will say for your
question about the towel senator i am
deeply puzzled about the underlying
theory that when the portion of the
loans that are already a hundred percent
guaranteed it can't be sold in the
marketplace and somehow we need to pay
hedge funds in order to get involved in
the sale of those loans this is a I'm
struggling to understand the premise
behind this portion of the program and
therefore struggling to understand how
it is that it will increase small
business lending this is something i
hope i will have a better answer in
another month we are working we are
investigating this right now we are
looking for more answers on it but i can
only say at this point this is a top
priority for the congressional oversight
panel and an area where we are deeply
troubled by the direction the treasury
has gone yeah so i think what you're
saying is we weren't explicit enough
when we wrote the legislation and I
don't know whether maybe this is too
transparent on my part but you know I
think that maybe Congress was awed by a
person that comes off a wall street
making tens and tens of millions of
dollars salary before he comes into the
cabinet odd that you think he's got all
the answers and then you find out when
it's all said and done he doesn't know a
whole lot more about it than we in
Congress do that are very gentlest and I
think that's why this legislation was so
poorly written in the first place at
least based upon what you just told me
it's a it's you know if we wanted to do
small business we should have said so
more
uh my last question this is to mr. bar
chefs chef I've reviewed AI geez
retention bonus plans what bothers me is
that the so-called retention bonuses
were really performance bonuses based on
207 2007 performance from the design of
the plan it looks like people who put it
together knew that the 2008 performance
was going to be bad so because the aig
knew it wasn't going to be paying
performance bonuses in 2008 in a wink
and a nod AIG simply paid its employees
there are two thousand seven performance
bonuses a second time and they'll do it
again in 2009 unless regardless of the
company's performance however a aiji's
disclosure of the plan to investors in
It's Made 2008 filing with SEC did not
make that clear it just describes a
tension plan in vague terms without
mentioning that it was calculated on
2007 performances I've got three
questions and I'll ask you to answer
them separately is it possible to find
out whether people at AIG wrote the
bonus plan based on the 2007 performance
because they knew a AIG was facing
massive losses in 2008 yes that'll be
part of an ongoing audit that we had
will capture that information if it is
true that management rigged the bonus
plan for that reason and failed to
properly disclose that to investors
would that be a potential violation of
securities law an intentional
misrepresentation of material fact if it
met that criteria would certainly
potentially be a violation of the
criminal law do you happen to know
whether SEC is examining whether the
disclosure of the bonus plan was
adequate we coordinate with the SEC on a
regular basis but I'd be reluctant to
comment on any pending or existing
matter okay but you you can't comment on
it but do you think you know senator I'm
sorry I don't mean to be to be overly
cautious here but we generally don't
comment on other agencies activities
unless that they're public well I
shouldn't push you to do something you
can
do unless you're trying to get around me
and I don't think you are never senator
ever sign o better okay since the aig is
a major recipient of TARP funds are you
able to investigate whether a disclosure
of the bonus plan was adequate I we can
and we will okay now for the Chairman
and all the other members thank you for
this fine testimony and we're obviously
going to have to be in touch with you on
a regular basis i hope the Chairman will
call you back frequently thank you very
much thank you very meeting adjourned
thank you son
you